It's This American Life from WBEZ Chicago, I'm Ira Glass.
这是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Valentine's Day is around the corner, and here at the show we were talking about romantic comedies and how they don't get a lot of respect. I think it's maybe because of the bad ones. Every part of them just feels too obvious, you know? The couple meets, but they hate each other at first. They go through some things that make them, you know, learn some important lesson about themselves. You know from the very beginning they're going to end up together. And then, no surprise, they do. When it's not done well, it's all too obvious and tired, and you can feel the gears working in the thing.
情人节就要到了，我们节目组一直在谈论浪漫喜剧，以及它们为何得不到应有的尊重。我想这可能是因为烂片太多了。它们每一个部分都显得太刻意了，对吧？男女主角相遇，起初却互相讨厌。他们经历了一些事情，让他们学到了关于自己的人生课题。从一开始你就知道他们最终会在一起。果然不出所料，他们确实在一起了。如果拍得不好，整个剧情就显得过于显眼和乏味，你甚至能感觉到剧本在生硬地运转。
One of the producers on our show, Neil, he wholeheartedly really loves romantic comedies, has favorites that he's watched over and over dozens of times. He once collaborated with the producer of Sleepless in Seattle on a rom-com script that never got made. He has all kinds of thoughts about them.
我们节目的制作人之一尼尔，他由衷地热爱浪漫喜剧，他有几十次反复观看的最爱电影。他曾与《西雅图夜未眠》的制作人合作编写过一部从未投拍的浪漫喜剧剧本。他对这些电影有着各种各样的见解。
And he realized this thing about rom-coms and what's so satisfying about the good ones that I really think is true.
他意识到关于浪漫喜剧的一点，以及优秀浪漫喜剧为何如此令人满足，我认为这确实是事实。
I used to say that it was just watching just the close-ups of two beautiful people being funny and clever and witty to each other.
我以前常说，浪漫喜剧吸引人只是因为看两个漂亮的人在一起搞笑、聪明、风趣。
Yeah.
是啊。
Being their sort of best selves, or sometimes worst selves, but then eventually their best selves. And that was kind of enough for me.
展示他们最好的一面，有时也是最坏的一面，但最终是最好的一面。对我来说，这已经足够了。
Now, why shut me out? You know what happens to people who shut everybody out?
为什么要把我拒之门外？你知道那些把所有人都拒之门外的人会怎样吗？
They live the quiet, peaceful lives?
他们过着安静平和的生活？
No, they fester.
不，他们会溃烂。
That's Meg Ryan and Kevin Kline with a fake French accent in the movie French Kiss.
那是梅格·瑞恩和凯文·克莱恩在电影《情定巴黎》中带着伪造的法国口音。
Fester. I am festering.
溃烂。我正在溃烂。
Inside, fester and rot. I've seen it happen. You'll become one of those hunched-back lonely old men sitting in the corner of a crowded cafe mumbling to yourself, (FRENCH ACCENT) my ass is twitching. You people make my ass twitch.
在内心深处，溃烂腐败。我见过这种情况。你会变成那种驼着背、孤独的老人，坐在拥挤咖啡馆的角落里喃喃自语，（法国口音）我的屁股在抽搐。你们这些人让我的屁股抽搐。
If there's there's a simple thing that resonates for me, it's that, in the best of these movies, you get to see two people get along in a way that is great.
如果有什么简单的事情能引起我的共鸣，那就是在最好的电影里，你能看到两个人以一种很棒的方式相处。
It's just like nice to see that part of people.
看到人们那温柔的一面真好。
Yeah. Yeah. And I think, if you're projecting at all, it's the idea that you can be that connected to someone or receive someone that well. When you see it, you're like, oh, yeah, that would be nice. That's why I like the ones where people spend a lot of time together.
是的。是的。我认为，如果你产生了一点共鸣，那是源于这样一种想法：你可以与某人建立那样的连接，或者得到某人那样的回应。当你看到时，你会觉得，哦，对啊，那该多好。这就是为什么我喜欢那些主角花很多时间在一起的电影。
That's key for Neil. In Neil's personal ranking of these films, which has the 2009 film The Ugly Truth at the very, very bottom, the three rom-coms that sit at the very top like the tousled hair above Hugh Grant's head, are French Kiss, Two Weeks Notice, which is a real estate rom-com, and his very favorite-- lots of people's favorite-- When Harry Met Sally. And they're all at the top of the list for this very reason, because of how much time the couple spends together talking. Take When Harry Met Sally.
这对尼尔来说是关键。在尼尔个人的电影排名中，2009年的《丑陋的真相》排在最末，而排在前三名的浪漫喜剧，就像休·格兰特头顶蓬乱的头发一样，分别是《情定巴黎》、《贴身情人》（一部关于房地产的浪漫喜剧），以及他最喜欢的，也是许多人最喜欢的《当哈利遇到莎莉》。它们之所以都排在榜首，正是因为男女主角在一起交谈的时间很多。看看《当哈利遇到莎莉》。
The thing that I like about it is that at least you get a vision of what their relationship actually is, because they spend 12 years together before they finally get together. So you get to see real fights. You get to see their relationship grow. You get to see their personalities clash.
我喜欢这部电影的原因是，至少你能看到他们真实的恋爱过程，因为他们在最终走到一起之前，已经在一起相处了12年。所以你能看到真实的争吵。你能看到他们关系的成长。你能看到他们个性的碰撞。
And so they actually have a chance to fall in love by talking to each other, as opposed to, in romantic comedies now, or like where there's the montage and music playing and then you're just supposed to come out of that thinking they're in love, they actually spend time with each other. Like there's a sequence of scenes in When Harry Met Sally where they're just getting along, and they're just talking on the phone.
他们确实有机会通过交谈相爱，而不是像现在的浪漫喜剧那样，只有一段配着音乐的蒙太奇镜头，你就默认他们相爱了。他们是真正花时间陪伴彼此。比如《当哈利遇到莎莉》里有一系列场景，他们只是相处得很好，在电话里聊天。
Hello?
喂？
You sleeping?
你睡了吗？
No, I was watching Casablanca.
没，我在看《卡萨布兰卡》。
Channel, please.
频道，谢谢。
11.
11频道。
Thank you. Got it. Now, you're telling me you would be happier with Victor Laszlow than with Humphrey Bogart?
谢谢。收到了。现在，你告诉我你会觉得和维克多·拉兹洛在一起比和亨弗莱·鲍嘉在一起更幸福？
When did I say that?
我什么时候说过那话？
When we drove to New York.
我们开车去纽约的时候。
I never said that. I would never have said that.
我从来没说过。我绝不可能那样说。
All right, fine. Have it your way. Have you been sleeping?
好吧，随你便。你一直在睡觉吗？
Why?
为什么？
Because I haven't been sleeping.
因为我一直睡不着。
I think if I was dating someone who hated When Harry Met Sally, I don't know that I could date them. Like, [LAUGHS] I don't know that I could. If you're not interested in the relationship between Harry and Sally, I don't really understand what kind of person you are. [LAUGHS] I don't know.
我觉得如果我和一个讨厌《当哈利遇到莎莉》的人约会，我不知道我是否能和他们继续下去。（笑）我不知道能不能。如果你对哈利和莎莉的关系不感兴趣，我真的不知道你是哪种人。（笑）我不知道。
Wow.
哇。
That's not to say that you're a bad person, it just means I don't think I understand you.
这并不是说你是个坏人，只是意味着我觉得我无法理解你。
OK. Romantic comedies are contrived. The people are way more clever and way better looking than in real life. The stories are full of things that would be ridiculous and sometimes maybe even on the stalker-y side if they happened to any of us. But this totally artificial form, when it works, reminds you of what it feels like to be in love and of somebody who wants to listen to what you say and who says things that you want to listen to. And so for this Valentine's Day, we're devoting our show to rom-coms.
好吧。浪漫喜剧确实很刻意。电影里的人比现实生活中更聪明、更好看。故事里充满了如果发生在我们身上会显得荒谬，甚至有些跟踪狂倾向的情节。但这种完全虚构的形式，在运作良好时，会让你想起恋爱是什么感觉，想起有一个人愿意倾听你说话，并且会说出你想听的话是什么感觉。所以在这个情人节，我们把节目献给浪漫喜剧。
In each of our acts today, we found a story that reminds us of some aspect of a movie rom-com. And yes, we did go on a search for stories of people running, sprinting down the street in real life in an urgent rush to tell someone that they love them. Stay with us.
在我们今天的每一个章节里，我们都找到了一个让我们想起浪漫喜剧电影某个侧面的故事。没错，我们确实去寻找了在现实生活中，人们为了告诉心爱的人“我爱你”而急切奔跑、冲刺在大街上的故事。请继续收听。
Act One, Meet Cute. So the first thing a rom-com needs is for the couple to meet in an appealing way, the meet cute.
第一幕，初次相遇。浪漫喜剧的第一要素就是男女主角要以一种引人入胜的方式相遇，即“初遇”。
The meet cute is supposed to make you feel like no matter what happens, these two people should be together.
初遇应该让你感觉到，无论发生什么，这两个人都注定要在一起。
There are so many ways to do this. In The Wedding Planner, Matthew McConaughey saves Jennifer Lopez from a runaway dumpster that is rolling down the street. In Pretty Woman, Richard Gere gets lost in a very fancy car and Julia Roberts gives him directions. Bringing Up Baby, Katherine Hepburn picks up Cary Grant's golf ball on a golf course. In Reality Bites, Winona Ryder throws her cigarette into Ben Stiller's car. And Neil's favorite, When Harry Met Sally--
达成这种效果的方式有很多。《爱上新郎》中，马修·麦康纳从滚下街头的垃圾箱里救了詹妮弗·洛佩兹。《风月俏佳人》中，理查·基尔开着豪车迷了路，朱莉娅·罗伯茨为他指路。《育婴奇谭》中，凯瑟琳·赫本在球场捡起了加里·格兰特的球。《四个毕业生》中，薇诺娜·瑞德把烟头扔进了本·斯蒂勒的车里。而尼尔最爱的《当哈利遇到莎莉》——
The thing about When Harry Met Sally is it has an extended meet cute, which I like. They take a road trip from Chicago to New York, and so they're kind of meeting for several hours. And from the very beginning, it's contentious because Harry has all these theories about relationships that she finds like crazy and off-putting.
关于《当哈利遇到莎莉》，我喜欢的是它有一个延长的初遇过程。他们从芝加哥开车到纽约，所以他们实际上相处了好几个小时。从一开始就充满火药味，因为哈利对人际关系有一套理论，而莎莉觉得那很疯狂且令人反感。
What I'm saying is-- and this is not a come on in any way, shape, or form-- is that men and women can't be friends because the sex part always gets in the way.
我要说的是——这绝不是为了搭讪——男人和女人无法成为朋友，因为性总是会横插一脚。
That's not true. I have a number of men friends and there is no sex involved.
那不是真的。我有很多男性朋友，我们之间根本没有涉及性。
No, you don't.
不，你没有。
Yes, I do.
我有。
No, you don't.
不，你没有。
Yes, I do.
我有。
You only think you do.
你只是以为你有。
You're saying I'm having sex with these men without my knowledge?
你的意思是，我是在自己不知情的情况下和这些男人发生了性关系吗？
No, what I'm saying is they all want to have sex with you.
不，我的意思是他们都想和你发生性关系。
They do not.
他们不想。
Do too.
他们想。
They do not.
他们不想。
Do too.
他们想。
I think it sets up the chemistry. Like it sets up that there is something about them that you want to root for.
我认为这建立了化学反应。这确立了他们身上有某种让你想要支持他们的特质。
Meet cutes do happen in real life, but for this first story in today's show, we have a piece of fiction, a story where the meet cute plays an important role in the story as a turning point for one of the characters. The story's by Simon Rich. The actor Daniel Radcliffe read it for us.
初遇在现实中确实会发生，但今天节目的第一个故事是一篇小说，一个初遇在故事中作为角色转折点的故事。故事作者是西蒙·里奇。演员丹尼尔·雷德克里夫为我们朗读。
"I don't understand," Professor Xander Kaplan said while his girlfriend sobbed into a pillow. "I thought you liked tulips." "I do," she said. "It's just-- you get them for me every year. It's starting to get a little impersonal. I mean, this time, you didn't even include a card."
“我不明白，”赞德·卡普兰教授看着女友埋在枕头里啜泣，“我以为你喜欢郁金香。”“我是喜欢，”她说，“只是……你每年都送这个，开始觉得有点没诚意了。我的意思是，这次你甚至连卡片都没放。”
Xander winced. Her reasoning was sound. "I apologize," he said. "I obviously made an error in judgment." He tried to take her hand, but she pulled it out of reach. "Do you remember what I did for your birthday?" She said, "I got you that new Bunsen burner you wanted. I knit you a pair of wool socks so your feet wouldn't get cold in the lab. You never make that kind of effort for me. All you do is think about yourself."
赞德畏缩了。她的理由很有道理。“我道歉，”他说，“我显然判断失误了。”他试图去拉她的手，但她躲开了。“你记得你为我的生日做了什么吗？”她说，“我给你买了你想要的那个本生灯。我为你织了一双羊毛袜，这样你在实验室里脚就不会冷。你从来不会为我付出那样的努力。你只关心你自己。”
"That's incorrect," Xander said. "What about Emiladium? It took me nine months to synthesize that element and I named it after you." "You were going to synthesize that element anyway," Emily said. "You needed it for your secret project, that silver orb thing in your lab. Emiladium wasn't about me, it was about you. I mean, for god sakes, you won't even tell me what it does."
“这不准确，”赞德说，“埃米利亚元素呢？我花了九个月才合成出那个元素，而且是以你的名字命名的。”“你反正都要合成那个元素，”艾米丽说，“你需要它来完成你的秘密计划，就是你实验室里那个银色的球状物。埃米利亚元素不是关于我的，是关于你自己的。老天，你甚至不告诉我它是干什么用的。”
Xander sighed. "Is there anything I can do to make it up to you?" Emily blinked back some tears. "I don't know. I mean, it's not like you can just go back in time and get me a different present." Xander's expression brightened. "Wait there," he said. "I'll be right back."
赞德叹了口气。“我能做些什么来补偿你吗？”艾米丽眨去泪水。“我不知道。我的意思是，你又不能回到过去给我换个礼物。”赞德的表情亮了起来。“在那儿等着，”他说，“我马上回来。”
Xander hurried down the hall, crept into his laboratory, and locked the door behind him. His time machine was right where he had left it. He climbed inside the silver orb and flicked on the power switch. His plan was simple, travel back in time to this morning, find a new gift for Emily, and bring it to the present. But there were a couple of risks.
赞德匆忙穿过走廊，溜进实验室，反锁了门。他的时间机器就在他离开的地方。他爬进银色球体，拨动了电源开关。他的计划很简单：回到今天早上，为艾米丽找一份新礼物，然后带到现代。但有几个风险。
There was a chance, for example, that using the machine would cause the universe to explode. He'd never tested the thing out before. There was also no guarantee that he would be able to find a good present. He only had enough Emiladium to fuel five minutes of time travel. That didn't give him a lot of wiggle room. Wherever he went, he would have to shop efficiently.
例如，使用机器可能会导致宇宙爆炸。他以前从未测试过这玩意儿。此外，他也不能保证能找到一份好礼物。他剩下的埃米利亚元素只够进行五分钟的时间旅行。这并没有给他留下多少周旋余地。无论他去哪儿，都必须高效地购物。
Xander was usually a pretty good problem solver. He had, for example, invented a time machine. But quantum physics and nuclear hydraulics were trivial compared to the rigors of gift shopping. He massaged his temples, trying to remember if Emily had dropped any hints lately. He vaguely recalled her staring at a vase in Crate & Barrel, but that place was full of vases. There was no way he'd be able to pick out the right one.
赞德通常是一个相当不错的解题者。比如，他发明了时间机器。但量子物理和核水力学与选礼物的严格要求相比，简直微不足道。他揉了揉太阳穴，试图回忆艾米丽最近是否透露过什么线索。他模糊地想起她盯着Crate & Barrel商店里的一只花瓶看，但那地方到处都是花瓶。他不可能选出正确的那一个。
He was trying to remember the name of her favorite perfume when a thought entered his head. Maybe he was thinking too small. His machine could transport him to any time and place in human history. Why go back a few hours when he could go back a few centuries?
他正试图想起她最喜欢的香水名字时，一个念头进入了他的脑海。也许他想得太狭隘了。他的机器可以将他传送到人类历史上的任何时间和地点。为什么只回去几个小时，而不是回去几个世纪呢？
He knew Emily loved Shakespeare. She'd written her senior thesis on one of his tragedies. Why not travel back to the Globe Theater and swipe her an original script? It wouldn't be too difficult, he reasoned. All he'd have to do is dash back backstage and grab one. It would be the most impressive gift she'd ever received in her life.
他知道艾米丽喜欢莎士比亚。她的大四论文就是关于他的一部悲剧。为什么不回到环球剧场去顺走她的原始剧本呢？他推断，这不会太难。他只需要冲进后台抢走一本。这将是她一生中收到的最令人印象深刻的礼物。
But which tragedy had Emily written her thesis about? He knew it was one of the king ones, Richard the something or Charles the something, but there are a bunch of those. What if he got it wrong? It was too risky.
但艾米丽的论文写的是哪部悲剧？他知道是那些国王系列中的一部，理查什么或者查理什么，但那有一大堆。如果拿错了怎么办？这太冒险了。
There was always jewelry. He knew the general construction dates for King Tut's tomb. He could park in front of the pyramid, run inside, and snatch a jade stone. He entered the coordinates and was about to push the lever when he started to second guess himself again.
还有珠宝。他知道图坦卡蒙墓的大致建造日期。他可以停在金字塔前，跑进去抢一块翡翠。他输入了坐标，正要按下操纵杆时，他又开始动摇了。
Buying women jewelry was always chancy. Emily had very specific tastes, and what if she didn't like jade? It wasn't like he'd be able to go back and return it.
给女人买珠宝总是很冒险。艾米丽有非常独特的品味，如果她不喜欢翡翠怎么办？他又不能回去退货。
He thought back to the night they met. He was finishing his PhD at the time, and his lab had closed early because of Easter. He'd stuffed his papers into his briefcase and shuffled through the rain to the 116th Street Station. It was 4:05 AM and the platform was deserted, except for Emily.
他回想起他们相遇的那天晚上。那时他正在攻读博士学位，他的实验室因为复活节提前关闭了。他把文件塞进公文包，冒雨挪到了116街车站。当时是凌晨4:05，除了艾米丽，站台上空无一人。
It had been several days since Xander's last conversation with a human, and when she started to speak to him, he felt the stirrings of a panic attack. But Emily's friendly smile managed, somehow, to put him at ease. She was awfully cheerful, given her circumstances. Her MetroCard had expired, she said, and the machines were broken. She'd been stranded for over 20 minutes. Would he be willing to sell her a ride?
距离赞德上一次与人交谈已经过去好几天了，当她开始和他说话时，他感到了一阵恐慌。但艾米丽友好的微笑不知怎的让他放松了下来。考虑到当时的情况，她出奇地乐观。她说她的地铁卡过期了，而且售票机坏了。她已经被困了20多分钟。他愿意帮她刷一下卡吗？
Xander nodded and watched as she rooted around in her purse for some cash to pay him back. It was a moment or two before it occurred to him that she had given him the chance to be gallant.
赞德点点头，看着她在钱包里翻找现金想还他钱。过了一会儿，他才意识到，她给了他一个展示骑士风度的机会。
"You-- you don't have to reimburse me," he said. "I'll swipe you in for free." She thanked him enthusiastically and then, shockingly, wrapped her arms around his torso. Xander wasn't used to physical contact. And although the hug was brief, it caused his entire body to tingle from head to toe. It was a startling sensation, like walking through an electrically-charged field. He still felt that way whenever she touched him.
“你……你不需要还我钱，”他说，“我免费帮你刷。”她热情地感谢了他，然后，令人震惊地，她抱住了他的上半身。赞德不习惯身体接触。虽然拥抱很短暂，但却让他全身从头到脚感到刺痛。这是一种令人吃惊的感觉，就像走过一个带电的磁场。每当她触摸他时，他依然有这种感觉。
Xander was an atheist and believed fiercely in random causality. But by the end of their shared subway ride, he was sure he'd experienced a miracle. This wonderful person had shown up out of nowhere and given him a chance at love. And in return, he'd given her three years of misery.
赞德是一名无神论者，坚信随机因果关系。但在共享地铁旅程结束时，他确定自己经历了一个奇迹。这个美好的人凭空出现，给了他一次恋爱的机会。而作为回报，他却给了她三年的痛苦。
He thought about all of his Saturday nights at the lab, ignoring her calls, making excuses. He thought about the way she cried when he handed her the tulips. How could he make up for three years of romantic ineptitude with a single birthday present?
他想起自己所有在实验室度过的周六晚上，无视她的电话，编造借口。他想起当他把郁金香递给她时，她哭泣的样子。他怎么能用一个生日礼物来弥补三年的浪漫无能呢？
He closed his eyes and concentrated. There had to be a right answer. Cleopatra's crown. Joan of Arc's sword. A baby dinosaur. What was the greatest thing he could give her, the very best present in the world? It was the hardest problem he'd ever attempted to solve. But then, as always, the solution came to him.
他闭上眼睛，集中精神。一定有一个正确的答案。克利奥帕特拉的皇冠。贞德的剑。一只恐龙宝宝。什么才是他能给她的最伟大的东西，世界上最好的礼物？这是他尝试解决过的最难的问题。但随后，一如既往，解决方案浮现在他脑海中。
Xander parked his time machine by the 116th Street Station and dashed into the subway. It was 3:45 AM a little over three years in the past. Emily was standing by the turnstile, swiping and re-swiping her expired MetroCard. He took a deep breath and approached her.
赞德把他的时间机器停在116街车站，冲进地铁。现在是凌晨3:45，也就是三年多以前。艾米丽正站在旋转闸门旁，一遍又一遍地刷她那张过期的地铁卡。他深吸一口气，走近她。
"Let me guess," he said. "Expired MetroCard?" She chuckled. "How'd you know?" "I had a hunch. Come on, I'll swipe you through." "Oh, that's OK," she said. "I'll just go to the machine upstairs or--" "The machines are all broken," he said. "You'd better catch this one," he said. "The next one won't come for another 20 minutes."
“让我猜猜，”他说，“地铁卡过期了？”她笑了笑。“你怎么知道？”“我有种预感。来吧，我帮你刷过去。”“哦，没关系，”她说，“我上去找售票机或者……”“售票机都坏了，”他说，“你最好赶上这一班，”他说，“下一班要等20分钟。”
Before she could protest, he took out his MetroCard and swiped her through the turnstile. She smiled back at him with confusion. "Aren't you coming?" she asked as the train pulled into the station. Xander averted his eyes. He worried that if he looked at her, he would start to cry.
在她抗议之前，他拿出地铁卡，帮她刷过了闸门。她困惑地回以微笑。“你不一起吗？”当列车驶入车站时她问道。赞德避开了目光。他担心如果看着她，他会哭出来。
"I need to take a different train," he said. "Well, at least let me pay you for the--" "That's all right," he said, his voice breaking. "It's a present."
“我得换乘另一趟车，”他说。“好吧，那至少让我付你……”“没关系，”他说，声音哽咽，“这是一个礼物。”
He was about to turn away when she leaned over the turnstile and hugged him. It was exactly as he remembered it, her long brown hair brushing softly against his neck, his entire body tingling with warmth. "Thanks," she said. He tried to say, you're welcome, but the words got caught in his throat. He waved goodbye as she boarded the train, then he marched out of the station alone.
他正要转身离开时，她俯身越过闸门拥抱了他。这和他记忆中一模一样，她长长的棕色头发轻柔地掠过他的脖子，他全身充满了温暖。谢谢，她说。他想说，不客气，但话语卡在了喉咙里。她登上列车时，他挥手告别，然后独自一人走出了车站。
Daniel Radcliffe reading the short story, "The Present" by Simon Rich from Rich's book, The Last Girlfriend on Earth. Radcliffe is also the star of Simon Rich's new TV show, Miracle Workers, which will be out soon on TBS. And he stars in a new film, Beast of Burden that comes out this month.
丹尼尔·雷德克里夫朗读了西蒙·里奇的短篇小说《礼物》，摘自里奇的书《地球上最后一个女友》。雷德克里夫也是西蒙·里奇新电视剧《奇迹缔造者》的主演，该剧即将于TBS播出。他还是本月上映的新电影《困兽》的主演。
Act Two, The Obstacle.
第二幕，障碍。
The main body of most romantic comedies is there's something or a group of things keeping them apart. There's always obstacles that are keeping these two people who are fated to be together apart.
大多数浪漫喜剧的主体都是某种或一群障碍阻碍了男女主角。总是有障碍让这两个注定要在一起的人分离。
The obstacles can be big or little. Tom Hanks isn't over his dead ex-wife in Sleepless in Seattle. In Notting Hill, a guy falls in love with somebody who's too famous for him. In Bridget Jones, she's going after the wrong guy, which, of course, is Pride and Prejudice, and, I don't know, so many films. It's one of the most common.
障碍可大可小。《西雅图夜未眠》中，汤姆·汉克斯走不出亡妻的阴影。《诺丁山》中，一个普通人爱上了一个对他来说太出名的人。《BJ单身日记》中，她追错了对象，当然，这源自《傲慢与偏见》，天知道还有多少电影。这是最常见的情节之一。
In When Harry Met Sally, they each are involved with other people for a lot of the film. But the real obstacle is that they're friends, which, in this film, has a special meaning, because if you remember when Harry met Sally on that car ride originally, he told her that he didn't think that men and women could ever just be friends. So this is new for him. Billy Crystal has a scene in the film with a sidekick character, a best friend, played by Bruno Kirby, where they talk about this.
在《当哈利遇到莎莉》中，他们在电影的大部分时间里都和别人有牵扯。但真正的障碍是他们是朋友，这在电影中有着特殊的意义，因为如果你记得当初哈利在车里见到莎莉时，他告诉她他认为男人和女人不可能仅仅是朋友。所以这对他是全新的。比利·克里斯托在电影中有一个与布鲁诺·柯比饰演的挚友互动的场景，他们谈到了这一点。
I don't understand this relationship.
我不理解这种关系。
What do you mean?
你指什么？
You enjoy being with her?
你喜欢和她在一起？
Yeah.
是啊。
You find her attractive?
你觉得她有吸引力？
Yeah.
是啊。
And you're not sleeping with her?
那你没跟她上床？
No.
没有。
You're afraid to let yourself be happy.
你害怕让自己幸福。
Why can't you give me credit for this? This is a big thing for me. I never had a relationship with a woman that didn't involve sex. I feel like I'm growing.
为什么你不能肯定我这一点？这对我很重要。我以前和女人的关系从来没离过性。我觉得我在成长。
We went out looking for a real-life couple facing some obstacle that kept them from being together, and that's not actually very hard to find. But one of our producers, Elna Baker, heard about a couple where the obstacle that confronted them, once the relationship got going, was pretty unusual. It was a couple one of her friends was in years ago.
我们去找了一对现实中面临障碍的恋人，这其实并不难找。但我们的制作人之一，埃尔娜·贝克，听说了一对情侣，一旦关系开始，他们面临的障碍非常不同寻常。那是她几年前的一位朋友的经历。
Quick warning to everybody who's listening to this podcast version of our show, there are some words that we have un-beeped in this and other stories in the program. If you don't want to hear that, maybe you're listening with kids, you can get a beeped version at our website, thisamericanlife.org. Anyway, here's Elna.
向收听此播客版本节目的各位提个醒，在这个故事和其他节目中，我们保留了一些未经消音的词汇。如果你不想听到这些，或者和孩子一起收听，可以在我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 获取消音版本。总之，这是埃尔娜。
My friend, Michelle Buteau, is one of the most audacious, ballsy people I know. And she brings this attitude into all aspects of her life, including relationships. This is a story about her and her boyfriend. It starts in the '90s, when she was 18, going to college, living in Miami. And as college students do, she adopted a new cool persona for herself, one that wore dark lipstick, cargo pants, and danced in reggae clubs every weekend.
我的朋友米歇尔·布托是我认识的最胆大、最强悍的人之一。她把这种态度带到了生活的方方面面，包括恋爱。这是一个关于她和男友的故事。故事始于90年代，当时她18岁，在上大学，住在迈阿密。正如大学生那样，她为自己采用了一个新的酷人设，穿着深色口红、工装裤，每个周末都在雷鬼俱乐部跳舞。
I loved dancing. I wanted to be a fly girl on In Living Color. I definitely would have been Snoop Dogg's video ho if I had the chance.
我热爱跳舞。我想成为《In Living Color》里的时尚女孩。如果我有机会，我绝对会当Snoop Dogg的MV舞女。
Yeah.
是啊。
And, yeah, I was out one night at a teeny bopper club, and that's where I saw him. I remember the smoke machine was working. It felt like we were at a bar mitzvah somewhere in Jersey. And literally, when the smoke cleared, I'm like, who is that tall boy with the khakis on and the big gold chain and the curly hair? How do I talk to him?
有一天晚上，我在一个青少年舞厅，就在那儿看到了他。我记得烟雾机开着。感觉就像是在泽西岛的某个犹太受戒仪式上。烟雾散去后，我心想，那个穿着卡其裤、戴着大金链、留着卷发的长腿男孩是谁？我该怎么跟他搭讪？
And I kind of just sort of like inched my way over to him on the dance floor. I remember doing this move where we're like-- we both sort of like roll into each other's body, and I can get a whiff of his Drakkar Noir and I was like, mm, yes, yes, yes. And my heart was beating so fast, I could hear it. And I'm like, oh, my god, this is what love is. I feel like a Puerto Rican Molly Ringwald.
我就在舞池里一点点蹭过去。我记得做了一个动作，我们就像……我们两个人的身体滚动到了一起，我闻到了他身上德拉卡·诺尔香水的味道，我心里想，嗯，就是这样。我的心脏跳得飞快，我都能听到心跳声。我心想，天哪，这就是爱情。我觉得自己像个波多黎各版的莫莉·林沃德。
Like in any good first encounter, there were magical coincidences.
像所有美好的初遇一样，有一些神奇的巧合。
We were walking out to the parking lot, and we realized we both had the same car, Mazda Protegees, both leased by our moms.
我们走到停车场时，意识到我们开了同一款车，马自达Protegee，都是我们妈妈租的。
Was that a moment where you're like, this is fate? I mean, not only did I go to this club--
那一刻你觉得这是缘分吗？我的意思是，不仅仅是我去了那个俱乐部——
Oh, definitely. I'm like, what? Like, out of all the cars in the world, out of all the dance clubs, you and me.
哦，肯定的。我心想，什么鬼？在这世界上所有的车里，在所有的舞厅里，竟然是你和我。
He was 18, too, but he seemed really grown up.
他也是18岁，但他看起来真的很成熟。
He worked at Best Buy selling DVDs, and he was also a drug dealer. And in my mind, I was like, oh, my god, he's so cool. He's so good at math. He counts so quickly.
他在百思买卖DVD，同时也是个毒贩。我当时心里想，天哪，他太酷了。他数学真好。他数钱数得真快。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
In case you're thinking, drug dealer, red flag, he was barely a drug dealer. He dealt weed. Nearly every woman I know has dated a weed dealer. They quickly got serious. And he was Michelle's first big relationship. He was funny, smart. They had good banter. And he was this incredibly accepting person, made her feel comfortable, confident about her body and about sex, which she'd never really felt before. She imagined a real future with him.
如果你还在想，毒贩？红旗警报。他几乎不算毒贩。他只卖大麻。我认识的几乎每个女人都和卖大麻的人约会过。他们的关系很快变得认真起来。他是米歇尔的第一段重要恋情。他有趣、聪明。他们很聊得来。他是一个极其包容的人，让她感到舒适，对自己的身体和性生活充满自信，这是她以前从未感受过的。她想象着和他拥有真实的未来。
The plan was-- I mean, looking back on it, it seems so basic, but just to be with each other, and to have fun, and to have kids, and to go out to dinner after a movie on a Friday night, you know, the Olive Garden, Cheesecake Factory, just kind of exist in a really cute apartment with beige carpet and white blinds. Yeah, the American Dream.
计划是——回想起来，这似乎太基本了，但就是在一起，享受乐趣，生孩子，周五晚上电影后出去吃晚餐，你知道，Olive Garden，芝士蛋糕工厂，就那样住在公寓里，有米色地毯和白色百叶窗。是的，这就是美国梦。
Fast forward three years into the relationship. Their lives are totally entwined. Their families are close. They vacation together. It was that point of no return place in a relationship where you're just like, here it is. This is it.
快进到恋爱三年后。他们的生活完全交织在一起。两家人很亲近。他们一起度假。这是恋情中一个回不去的地方，你只是觉得，就是这里了。这就是全部了。
But there was this one thing that seemed sort of off, a lack of photographic evidence, no pictures of himself as a kid, specifically no school pictures, no prom picture. Even his mom didn't have any shots of him. It was just weird. And then one night--
但有一件事显得有点不对劲，缺乏照片证据，没有他小时候的照片，特别是没有学校照片、没有毕业舞会照片。甚至他妈妈都没有他的照片。这真的很奇怪。然后有一天晚上——
I had a dream that he called me up. He told me that he never graduated high school. When I called him the next day and I was like I had this crazy dream, he just started crying. I could just hear him gently sobbing and he's like, not only did I not graduate high school, I don't even know how to read.
我做梦他给我打电话。他在梦里告诉我他高中从没毕业。第二天我给他打电话说我做了一个疯狂的梦时，他开始哭。我能听到他轻轻啜泣，他说，我不仅没高中毕业，我甚至根本不识字。
I'm just like, how? Like, I thought I knew you. Like, what? Like, haven't we read something together?
我当时就想，怎么可能？我觉得我了解你。这太不可思议了。我们难道没一起读过什么东西吗？
Their entire relationship flashed before her eyes, one moment after another. Suddenly, it all made sense.
他们恋爱的一幕幕瞬间在她眼前闪过。突然，一切都说得通了。
And I was going back. You know, I realized, like, oh my god, this is why we go to the same restaurant. We would go to the same restaurant, and he'd order the same thing because he couldn't read the menu.
我开始回想。我意识到，天哪，这就是为什么我们总是去同一家餐厅。我们会去同一家餐厅，他点一样的菜，因为他根本看不懂菜单。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
And he liked you go to restaurants that had pictures of the food. You know, I would write him poems and stuff and he's like, read them to me. You know, it's better when I hear it from you. And never wanted to go through his mail. I had to help him.
他喜欢去有食物照片的餐馆。你知道，我给他写诗什么的，他会说，读给我听。你知道，听你读更好。而且他从不想处理邮件。我不得不帮他。
When you stop and think about it, the fact that he'd been able to navigate the world convincingly and keep this from Michelle for over three years, it was an incredible feat. He must have been covering this up constantly.
当你静下来思考时，他能令人信服地应付世界并瞒着米歇尔三年多，这是一项了不起的成就。他一定一直在时刻掩盖这一点。
When he told me why he didn't know how to read, it just made my heart break even more. I mean, his dad died when he was young, and so his mom had to work three jobs. And he was depressed and just dropped out of the fifth grade, and nobody ever noticed. His mom didn't want to deal with it. And you know, I'm not judging because it must been so hard for her.
当他告诉我为什么他不识字时，我的心更碎了。他父亲在他很小的时候就去世了，所以他妈妈不得不做三份工作。他很抑郁，五年级就辍学了，没人注意到。他妈妈不想管这事儿。而且，我不评判，因为这对她来说一定很难。
The only thing that kept going through my mind, I remember, was, I want to save you. I want to help you. I want to make this better. You know, we're going to get back on track to what we had planned.
我记得我脑子里唯一闪过的念头是，我想拯救你。我想帮助你。我想让情况好转。我们要回到我们计划的轨道上来。
She was not going to allow this obstacle to push them apart. She jumped into action. This was before you could Google everything, so Michelle went to the library and did research on adult literacy. She broke it down into manageable steps and wrote out a timeline for him.
她不打算让这个障碍把他们分开。她立即采取行动。这发生在Google还没普及的时候，所以米歇尔去了图书馆，研究成人扫盲。她把它分解成可管理的步骤，并为他写了一个时间表。
My game plan for him was I had a list of places he could go to to go to night school, a therapist he could talk to, easy adult reading books, tips and tricks. It was like a whole sort of care package of how to just take it on. And he was really overwhelmed by it. I don't know. It's like, OK, this is a really big deal. I get it.
我的计划是，列出一个他可以去参加夜校的名单，一位他可以交谈的治疗师，简单的成人阅读书目，小窍门。就像一个完整的关怀包，告诉他该怎么解决这个问题。他被这些弄得不知所措。我不知道。就是，好吧，这是一件大事。我明白。
Michelle's dyslexic, and her boyfriend didn't have a learning disability. But still, she could empathize with how hard it can be to read. And at first, Michelle's boyfriend was totally on board with the plan. But after a year of Michelle offering him solutions, he still hadn't taken any action. It just seemed like he didn't want to. He got around the world just fine without reading. She started realizing, oh wait, his illiteracy was a way bigger problem for her than it was for him, and it really started pushing them apart.
米歇尔有阅读障碍，而她男友没有学习障碍。但即便如此，她也能体会到阅读有多难。起初，米歇尔的男友完全赞成这个计划。但在米歇尔提供了一年解决方案后，他仍然没有任何行动。看起来他根本不想学。他不用识字也能在世界上过得挺好。她开始意识到，等等，他的文盲问题对她来说比对他自己要严重得多，这真的开始让他们分道扬镳。
I stopped being his girlfriend and sort of became his coach or his mom, and it wasn't fun for either one of us. I tried every tactic. I was patient. I was nice. I was stern. And then I kind of backed off. I'm like, whatever. He needs to do on his own time.
我不再是他的女朋友，反而成了他的教练或者妈，这对我们俩来说都不好玩。我尝试了每一种策略。我耐心。我友善。我严厉。然后我退出了。我想，随便吧。他得按照自己的节奏去做。
It started to bleed its way into every moment they shared together, like she could never fully relax anymore. Even when they were happy, she'd snap herself out of it and think, wait, no, no. We're forgetting that there's this huge, looming problem, and we've got to fix it before everything can be OK. She started to resent him.
这开始渗透到他们共同生活的每一个时刻，她再也无法完全放松了。即使他们开心的时候，她也会突然警醒并想，等等，不，不。我们忘了有一个巨大的、迫在眉睫的问题，我们得在一切好起来之前解决它。她开始怨恨他。
We don't even laugh anymore. We're not even holding hands like we used to. We're not even having sex like we used to, simply because you're not even going to this class. Like, if you just went to a class, I would just be so happy.
我们甚至不再一起笑了。我们甚至不像以前那样牵手了。我们甚至不像以前那样有性生活了，仅仅因为你根本不去上课。如果你只要去上课，我就会非常开心。
Did you feel like, if you love me, you will learn to read?
你是否觉得，如果你爱我，你就会学习阅读？
Absolutely. I mean, is that weird? But I totally felt like that. I was like, who's going to read books to our kids at night? Like, you've got to get it together.
绝对。我是不是很怪？但我确实是那样想的。我想，以后谁给我们的孩子读睡前故事？你必须把这些搞定。
This was like the bane of my existence. I was like-- and I couldn't really talk to anyone about it, because how embarrassing. Because I didn't want my friends to think less of him, you know? And I wanted him to still feel like a man, so I just kind of carried this by myself. And at some point, I just looked at myself and I was like, you've got to go. But even then, it was just like, how do I leave somebody when they're down?
这简直是我生活的痛苦源泉。我……我真的没法跟任何人说，因为太丢人了。因为我不想让我的朋友们看轻他，你知道吗？而且我希望他依然感觉像个男人，所以我只能自己扛着。到了某个时刻，我看着自己想，你必须离开。但即便在那时，我也在想，当一个人处于低谷时，我怎么能离开他呢？
Well, in a sense it actually-- like, it made the relationship last longer because everything became about him reading. And so if you could just crack that or fix that, then maybe it would work out.
嗯，某种意义上，这其实……这让恋情持续得更久，因为一切都围绕着他阅读的问题。所以如果你能突破那个点或解决那个问题，那么也许就能成功。
Oh, my god, what are you? Dr. Phil with tits? [LAUGHTER] Yeah, I mean, I feel like I always live like that. If I could just lose those 20 pounds. If I could just have a clean house all the time, I could do everything I really want to do on my list. And so, yeah, there was that. You know, if we could just get past this, then we'll live the life we're supposed to live.
天哪，你是什么？穿裙子的菲尔博士吗？（笑）是啊，我觉得我总是那样活着。如果我能减掉那20磅。如果我能让房子一直保持整洁，我就能完成清单上我想做的一切。所以，是的，就是那样。你知道，如果我们能跨越这个障碍，那么我们就能过上我们该过上的生活。
That's the promise of an obstacle. You feel like all you have to do is conquer it, and you get your happy ending. How would it play out in a rom-com?
这就是障碍带来的承诺。你觉得只要征服它，就能得到幸福的结局。在浪漫喜剧里会怎么演绎呢？
The obstacle being his illiteracy?
障碍是他的文盲？
Yeah.
是的。
Ooh, OK. Boom. He learns how to read. He writes a New York best seller situation. It becomes a movie. Channing Tatum plays him. Lisa Bonet plays me. And we live happily ever after with a bunch of mixed children in a huge apartment with beige carpet by the Cheesecake Factory.
噢，好。砰。他学会了阅读。他写了一本纽约畅销书。被拍成了电影。查宁·塔图姆演他。丽莎·博内特演我。我们和几个混血孩子住在芝加哥芝士蛋糕工厂旁那间铺着米色地毯的巨大公寓里，从此幸福地生活在一起。
Amazing. [LAUGHS] See, I was imagining that he would greet you at the airport with, like, a sign that he had handwritten himself that was like, Michelle, I can read now.
太棒了。（笑）看，我原本以为他会在机场迎接你，举着一块他亲手写的牌子，上面写着：米歇尔，我现在会阅读了。
Oh, my god.
天哪。
And then you'd see it, and you'd start crying. And you'd be like, oh! And he's worked so hard behind your back, secretly going to night school the whole time. Aww.
然后你看到了，就开始哭。你会说，噢！而且他一直在你背后努力，悄悄地去上夜校。哎呀。
I know. Instead, he just like fucked a stripper.
我知道。相反，他只是跟一个脱衣舞娘上床了。
OK, she wasn't a stripper, but she was sleeping with Michelle's boyfriend. Michelle suspects that the entire time she was struggling to get him to read, he was cheating on her. She was so focused on the obstacle she thought they were facing, she totally missed it. Of course, as rom-coms go, the thing missing from this story is com, at least until Michelle started doing stand up and figured out how to tell it on stage.
好吧，她不是脱衣舞娘，但她确实在和米歇尔的男友睡觉。米歇尔怀疑在她努力让他学习阅读的整个过程中，他都在背着她偷吃。她太专注于他们面临的那个障碍，完全错过了重点。当然，正如浪漫喜剧一样，这个故事里缺的是“喜剧”，直到米歇尔开始说脱口秀，并想出了如何在舞台上讲述这段经历。
When did you decide, this story's funny. I'm going to put it in my act? Because it's actually really sad, but--
你什么时候决定“这个故事挺有趣的，我要把它放进我的段子里”？因为它实际上非常悲伤，但——
Yeah, you know, most of my-- the first joke I ever wrote was about him.
是啊，你知道，我写的第一个段子就是关于他的。
Will you tell it to me?
你能告诉我吗？
Sure. It's lines at Disney World remind me of my ex-boyfriend, three hours of waiting for a two-minute ride. Ayo. But the story, I didn't feel comfortable doing it on stage till 13 years later.
当然。迪士尼世界的排队队伍让我想起了我的前男友，等待三小时，只为了两分钟的体验。哎哟。但关于这个故事，直到13年后我才觉得可以搬上舞台。
And I stayed with him, but then it got, like, real ratchet. Like, we would get into arguments, and I'd say shit like, but you said you'd learn how to read for me. Like, that's not how you want your first relationship to be.
我和他在一起过，但后来变得非常烂。比如，我们会吵架，我会说一些话，比如：可你说过你会为了我学习阅读的。那不是你想要的第一段恋情该有的样子。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
In her act, she even talks about how great it feels to tell this story on stage.
在段子里，她甚至谈到在舞台上讲述这个故事感觉有多好。
But it just felt so good. It was so cathartic. I was like, yes, I got to get this out. And I just started doing jokes about him and blogging about him. And my friends are like, you got to be careful, because you're using his first and last name.
但感觉太好了。这非常具有宣泄感。我就想，耶，我得把这些吐出来。我开始讲关于他的笑话，并在博客上写他。我的朋友们说，你得小心点，因为你用了他的全名。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
And I was like, bitch, I don't give a fuck, because that motherfucker can't read!
我说，碧池，我才不在乎呢，因为那个混蛋根本不识字！
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
All right. Good night, everybody. I got to go.
好了。晚安，各位。我得走了。
[CHEERING]
（欢呼声）
Elna Baker's one of the producers of our show. Michelle Buteau is going to be hosting a new podcast, Late Night Whenever from WNYC. It's going to launch in April.
埃尔娜·贝克是我们节目的制作人之一。米歇尔·布托将主持WNYC的新播客《Late Night Whenever》。它将于四月推出。
Coming up, a real life rom-com that involves Shakespeare, real kisses that are like stage kisses, and the police. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，一个涉及莎士比亚、像舞台吻一样真实的吻以及警察的现实浪漫喜剧。稍后回来，芝加哥公共广播，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, for Valentine's Day, "Rom Com," stories mostly taken from real life that mimic things that we have seen in romantic comedies. We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, The Run.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是为了情人节制作的“浪漫喜剧”，故事大多取自现实生活，模仿我们在浪漫喜剧中看到的情节。我们来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，奔跑。
This, of course, in a romantic comedy is the scene where somebody has to cross town at some point, literally sprinting to chase down the person they love and stop them from either marrying somebody else or winning them back somehow. It doesn't always end up at the airport, but lots of these do. And honestly, I have to say, I was surprised we found this ever happened in real life, but here is one story like that.
当然，这在浪漫喜剧中是男女主角必须横跨城市，字面上冲刺去追回他们所爱的人，阻止对方嫁给别人或以某种方式赢回对方。它并不总是在机场结束，但很多都是这样。老实说，我必须说，我惊讶地发现这在现实中确实发生过，但这里有一个这样的故事。
Marissa Kohan's dad used to like to tell the story. It was about his own marriage. He died a couple of years ago. His name is Ron. The story goes like this. When he was getting together with Marissa's mom, Marissa's mom, Debbie, drove across the country to move in with Ron in Florida. And before she left, she had the post office forward her mail to his house in Florida. And he saw a letter arrive from her ex-fiance.
玛丽莎·科汉的父亲过去喜欢讲这个故事。这是关于他自己的婚姻。他几年前去世了。他的名字叫罗恩。故事是这样的：当他和玛丽莎的母亲玛丽莎的母亲黛比走到一起时，黛比开车横跨全国去佛罗里达和罗恩住在一起。在出发前，她让邮局把她的邮件转寄到他在佛罗里达的家。他看到一封信从她的前未婚夫寄来。
I think it's crazy, but my dad decided that he saw that letter and he had to read it.
我觉得这很疯狂，但我爸决定既然看到了那封信，就必须读一读。
This is Marissa.
这是玛丽莎。
So he just opened the letter, read the whole thing. And as my dad put it, my mom's ex-fiance was declaring his undying love for her, and was begging her not to go, and was saying he wants to get back together with her. And my dad freaked out.
于是他拆开信，读了整封信。按照我爸的说法，我妈的前未婚夫正在表达对她永恒的爱，恳求她不要走，说他想和她破镜重圆。我爸当时就炸了。
He decided, this is it. It's now or never. He decides he's going to meet her in Dallas, which is where she is in her car trip, and also is where the ex-fiance lives. He hurries to the airport.
他决定，就是现在，机不可失。他决定去达拉斯接她，那是她开车路过的地方，也是前未婚夫住的地方。他匆忙赶往机场。
The way he told it was he was going through the airport, you know, running through the Florida airport. Gets a ring out of a little gumball machine. Puts, you know, however much that costs, a quarter or whatever, in the gumball machine, pulls out a Mickey Mouse ring-- because it's Florida, naturally. Gets on the plane. Flies and meets my mom in Dallas. And right there in the airport, gets down on one knee the second he sees her.
按照他的描述，他冲进机场，你知道，在佛罗里达机场奔跑。从一个小口香糖机里弄出一枚戒指。投入了，不管那要多少钱，一角硬币或者什么的，放进机子，掏出一枚米老鼠戒指——因为是在佛罗里达，很自然。上了飞机。飞到达拉斯见到我妈。就在机场里，一见到她就单膝下跪。
I had no plans of seeing the ex-fiance at all, whatsoever.
我完全没打算见那个前未婚夫，一点都没。
This is Marissa's mom, Debbie. She had no idea the ex-fiance had written a letter or that Ron had opened it. All she knew was that he had offered to drive the rest of the way across the country with her and was going to meet her in the Dallas airport.
这是玛丽莎的妈妈，黛比。她根本不知道前未婚夫写了信，也不知道罗恩拆了它。她只知道他提议开车陪她走完剩下的路，并要在达拉斯机场见她。
He gets off the plane, and I greet him. And practically the very next thing out of his mouth is, will you marry me? And he opens up his hand. And in his hand, he's got this little Mickey Mouse ring in his hand. And I am not proud of my reaction at all. [LAUGHS] Do you want to hear it?
他下了飞机，我去迎接他。他嘴里说的几乎下一句话就是，你愿意嫁给我吗？他摊开手。他手里握着那枚小小的米老鼠戒指。我一点也不为自己的反应感到骄傲。（笑）你想听听吗？
Yeah.
想。
[LAUGHS] My reaction was, are you crazy? This is the craziest thing I've ever heard of. I barely know you. That was my reaction.
（笑）我的反应是，你疯了吗？这是我听过最疯狂的事。我几乎不了解你。这就是我的反应。
I have to say, that is my favorite part of the story.
我得说，这是我最喜欢的故事部分。
I could have been a little more gentle.
我本来可以温和一点的。
No, what I love about it is that in the movies, when somebody does a gesture like that, often it's way crazier than what he did.
不，我喜欢它的是，在电影里，当某人做出那样的举动时，通常比他做的还要疯狂。
Yes.
是的。
And kind of stalker-ish. But the movie just acts like, oh, that was a totally lovely thing for a person to do because true love will out. And I like that you had the normal human reaction that a normal person would have. It would be like, are you nuts?
而且有点跟踪狂的感觉。但电影只是把它表现为，噢，那是一个人能做的非常可爱的事，因为真爱总会显现。我喜欢你有正常人会有的反应。那反应就像是，你神经病吗？
Right. Right. Right. Right. Yeah. Well, I'm too pragmatic to fall for that one, I guess.
对。对。对。对。是的。嗯，我太现实了，没法被那一招骗倒，我想。
True love eventually did win out though. At their wedding, in addition to a regular ring, she also wore the Mickey Mouse one.
真爱最终还是获胜了。在他们的婚礼上，除了普通的戒指，她还戴上了那枚米老鼠戒指。
There was another story we heard about somebody running to win love, which actually kind of paralleled the run that happens at the end of Neil's favorite rom-com, When Harry Met Sally. In When Harry Met Sally, the way it goes is that it's New Year's Eve. Harry's wandering around the streets of New York, and he realizes that he loves Sally, has to tell her now, breaks into a run to go tell her.
我们听到了另一个关于某人奔跑去赢取爱情的故事，这其实有点像尼尔最喜欢的浪漫喜剧《当哈利遇到莎莉》结尾的奔跑。《当哈利遇到莎莉》里，故事发生在新年前夜。哈利在纽约街头徘徊，他意识到自己爱莎莉，必须现在告诉她，于是冲刺去告诉她。
It's very New York-centric in this one because he tries to catch a cab, and of course he can't-- so he's just going to run the entire distance.
这一幕非常以纽约为中心，因为他试图拦出租车，当然他拦不到——所以他决定全程跑过去。
David Kestenbaum has our real-life version of this story, about a guy named Steve Snyder.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆带给我们这个故事的现实版本，关于一个叫史蒂夫·斯奈德的人。
The thought that someone actually made one of these runs in real life seems so unlikely to me that I wanted to see where it had happened, retrace the steps of it. So I met Steve where the run began, at this burger place on Ludlow Street in New York City. Steve is the kind of guy who is not very good at hiding his feelings. Like, if this were a movie, you could title it "Say Everything."
一个人在现实中真的做出这种奔跑的想法对我来说太不可思议了，所以我想要去看看它发生的地方，追溯它的脚步。所以我在史蒂夫奔跑的起点——纽约卢多街的一家汉堡店见到了他。史蒂夫属于那种不善于隐藏感情的人。如果这是一部电影，你可以把它命名为“有话直说”。
The setup to the run is this, he'd met this woman, Emily, at a birthday party. He was totally smitten.
奔跑的前奏是：他在一个生日派对上遇到了这个女人，艾米丽。他彻底沦陷了。
What I remember is the party kind of turned into sort of a tunnel vision moment. All I really did was talk to her.
我记得那场聚会变成了一种隧道视野的时刻。我唯一做的就是跟她聊天。
It didn't go great. He kept asking her, you want to go to a movie? Maybe we could hang out sometime.
进行得并不顺利。他一直问她，想去看电影吗？也许我们什么时候可以一起玩？
If there's a trajectory of my life, it's going from clingy to a little less clingy.
如果我的人生有一条轨迹，那就是从死缠烂打到稍微不那么死缠烂打。
Steve emailed her after the party. Nothing came of it.
史蒂夫在派对后发邮件给她。没什么结果。
A year passes. And just like in When Harry Met Sally, they meet a second time. In Steve and Emily's case, it's at the very same birthday party, same apartment. And they become friends. It was the kind of friendship where, really, it could go either way. She seemed kind of interested in something more, but maybe not enough. And the longer they were friends, it was like, well, maybe that's what they were.
一年过去了。就像《当哈利遇到莎莉》里一样，他们第二次见面了。在史蒂夫和艾米丽的例子中，是在同一个生日派对，同一个公寓。他们成了朋友。那是一种真的可能走向任何方向的友谊。她看起来对进一步发展有点兴趣，但也许不够。他们当朋友越久，就越像是，嗯，也许他们就是这样了。
Steve had a job as a film critic, so they would go to movies, lots of movies, where they would not hold hands and not kiss.
史蒂夫的工作是电影评论员，所以他们会去看电影，看很多电影，在那里他们不牵手也不接吻。
There is a pathetic moment. So Lincoln Center Station, we're waiting for the train. It's like some crazy, 20-minute wait where the words actually come out of my mouth, you know, hey, if you ever want a film critic as a boyfriend, you just let me know.
有一个悲惨的时刻。在林肯中心站，我们等火车。那是那种疯狂的20分钟等待，我嘴里竟然蹦出那句话，你知道，嘿，如果你什么时候想要个电影评论员当男友，你就告诉我。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
I think we were talking about-- it fit into the context of the conversation somehow, but I can't think of anything more pathetic.
我想当时是在谈论——它以某种方式契合了对话背景，但我实在想不出比这更悲惨的事了。
What was her reaction?
她的反应是什么？
She just kind of laughed and was like, yeah, OK, OK.
她只是笑了笑，说，嗯，好吧，好吧。
The run happened on a night where they were not going to hang out. Steve thinks he was working on a review of some Mutant Ninja Turtle movie. And after work, he goes out with some friends to a music place.
那次奔跑发生在一个他们原本不会见面的一天晚上。史蒂夫想他当时正在写一篇关于某部忍者神龟电影的影评。工作结束后，他和朋友们去了音乐场所。
Music's so loud and it's kind of fun. You know, it's a great night. And we're dancing. I actually started dancing for once. We leave the place. We're going to go get some greasy food because we're hungry and we haven't eaten. And I have my bag and everything, so we walk into the burger joint.
音乐很大声，挺有趣的。你知道，那是一个很棒的夜晚。我们在跳舞。我破天荒地开始跳舞。我们离开了那里。我们要去吃点油腻的东西，因为我们饿了，什么都没吃。我带着包什么的，所以我们走进了这家汉堡店。
The place we are sitting in right now-- greasy spoon, tiled white walls and painted brick. It's like a piece of a subway station that's somehow above ground.
我们现在坐的这个地方——路边摊，铺着瓷砖的白墙和粉刷过的砖块。感觉就像一个地下的地铁站不知怎么跑到了地面上。
You know, there's what, five tables here? It's tiny. And so I remember just kind of throwing my bag down. And then I pull out my phone just to check. And it's one of those weird nights, right? Like, I just haven't checked my phone almost any night-- any night, 99% of nights, you know, your phone's right next to you. If it's buzzing, you hear it. If it rings, you hear it.
你知道，这里有几张桌子？这里很小。我记得就把包一扔。然后我掏出手机看了看。那天晚上挺怪的，对吧？我基本上整晚都没看手机——任何晚上，99%的时间，你的手机就在身边。如果它震动，你会听到。如果它响了，你会听到。
I don't know if I had bad reception in the place because it's kind of an older building, but I looked down, and I swear to god, I have like 22 text messages. And I'm like, what? And they're all from Emily. And so I run out of the burger place to the street.
我不知道是因为它是老建筑导致收讯不好，但我低头一看，天哪，我有22条短信。我心想，什么？它们全来自艾米丽。于是我从汉堡店冲到街上。
Right, let's go outside.
好吧，去外面说。
[LAUGHS] OK.
（笑）好。
All right, so you rush out here.
好，所以你冲了出来。
I rush out here, and there's not exactly a lot of room. I mean, there's not room at all. So this is a crowded-- like, this is where you hang out till 4:00 AM.
我冲了出来，这里空间并不大。我是说，根本没地方。所以这是一个拥挤的地方——这是你一直聚会到凌晨4点的地方。
So I rush out and I start reading through the messages. And it starts very kind of innocently, very like, hey, what are you up to tonight? Oh, are you-- oh, maybe you're out? I was wondering if maybe you wanted to like get a drink or something? And then it starts escalating like, wait, are you not texting me? Or why aren't you texting me back?
所以我就冲了出来，开始阅读这些信息。一开始很天真，比如，嘿，你今晚在干嘛？噢，你在……噢，也许你出去了？我想知道你是否想去喝一杯什么的？然后开始升级，比如，等等，你为什么不回我信息？或者你为什么不理我？
Usually, he was pretty quick at getting back to her.
通常他回复她挺快的。
Because I was totally into her. And then it started being like-- it started getting a little more paranoid. And then I think she started thinking I was on a date or something.
因为我完全被她迷住了。然后它开始变得……变得有点偏执。然后我想她开始觉得我在约会什么的。
In just two hours, it looked like she'd gone through all these phases, everything laid out in all these texts, ending with one that Steve was not expecting.
仅仅两个小时内，看起来她经历了一切阶段，所有这些都在短信里体现出来，最后一条史蒂夫完全没料到。
And the last text message said, maybe we need to talk about this whole not dating thing. I just-- I-- I thought, this is it. Like whatever's about to happen, this is the moment. And so I immediately called her. I immediately just hit dial.
最后一条短信说，也许我们需要谈谈这整个“不约会”的事情。我只是……我想，就是现在了。不管发生什么，就是这一刻了。于是我立即拨了回去。我立即按了拨号。
I didn't quite know what I was going to say. And I think she picked up the phone, said, hello, and I just kind of started going into it, like, I don't know what to say here. Like, yes, I want to date you. And what have we been doing?
我不太知道我要说什么。我想她接起电话说，喂，我只是开始说了，比如，我不知道该说什么。比如，是的，我想和你约会。我们一直在干什么？
You know, I'm screaming in the street. The cars aren't moving. People stop walking by me. They just stop to see what's going on here, because I'm screaming like, I love you. I don't know how to be clearer, like, I love you. And so I'm screaming this. And this crowd is starting to cheer me on. Someone does yell, like, say you love him! Say you love him, yelling to her through the phone. And--
你知道，我在街上尖叫。车都没动。路人停下脚步，他们停下来看发生了什么，因为我在尖叫比如“我爱你”。我不知道怎么说得更清楚，我爱你。所以我尖叫着这个。人群开始为我欢呼。有人大喊，比如，说你也爱他！说你也爱他，对着电话朝她喊。然后——
I love New York. [LAUGHS]
我爱纽约。（笑）
And all I remember her saying, and it might have been all that she did say, was, you need to stop yelling. If you want to talk about this, you might as well just come here. And as far as I'm concerned, this is the moment-- like, it's on. This is happening. And I just start running down the street looking for cabs.
我记得她说的唯一一句话，也许也是她说的全部，就是，你需要停止尖叫。如果你想谈这个，你最好直接过来。在我看来，就是这一刻——开始了。这就是现实。于是我开始奔跑，寻找出租车。
Let's run. Let's run.
跑吧，跑起来。
[LAUGHS] OK. So I start running.
（笑）好。所以我就开始跑。
We are now jogging up Ludlow Street. It's actually kind of exciting.
我们现在正在卢多街上慢跑。其实挺刺激的。
The crowd's looking at me, wondering what the hell I'm doing. And literally, I'm banging on every cab, because it's that time of night where some are just saying they're off duty. So I think I hit a couple. And I'm sort of like, can you take me just up to the East Village, not that far?
人群看着我，纳闷我到底在干什么。我真的在敲每一辆出租车，因为那个点有的司机说他们下班了。我想我敲了好几辆。我当时就在想，你能带我去东村吗，又不远？
But taxi after taxi is like, no, or there's someone in it. So he keeps running.
但一辆接一辆的出租车都说不行，或者里面已经有人了。所以他继续跑。
It's like I didn't tell my friends where I was going. I left my laptop, all these screeners that I had taken assignments to review, that the movie studios told me they needed back. I ditched everything.
就像我没告诉朋友我要去哪儿。我丢下了笔记本电脑，丢下了电影公司交代的要回去复审的所有审片。我丢下了一切。
Can we talk about the running?
我们能聊聊那个奔跑吗？
Yeah.
可以。
Why does love always involve running?
为什么爱情总是涉及奔跑？
[LAUGHS] That is interesting. Why did I feel like I had to run?
（笑）那真有意思。为什么我觉得我非得跑不可？
In the movies, they run, but usually it's because someone's about to get married or about to get on a plane.
在电影里，他们奔跑，但通常是因为有人要结婚或者要登机。
It felt very urgent to get there very quick. This had been building up for years. And for a moment, she was willing to consider it. And I was going to get there before she said it was too late or she was too tired.
觉得必须快点赶到那里真的很迫切。这已经是几年来的积压了。有一刻，她愿意考虑一下。而我要赶在她改口说“太晚了”或者她太累了之前赶到。
Steve told me he'd been living in the friend universe for so long, and now it was like this little wormhole had opened up-- he didn't know for how long-- where he might be able to slip into the parallel universe of boyfriend. Steve did eventually get a taxi, he made it to her apartment, and he stayed over. And they did become boyfriend and girlfriend.
史蒂夫告诉我，他在“朋友宇宙”里待了太久，现在就像一个小虫洞打开了——他不知道会持续多久——他也许能滑进“男友的平行宇宙”。史蒂夫最终拦到了一辆出租车，赶到了她的公寓，并在那里过夜了。他们确实成了情侣。
In the movies, this is often the final scene. The end of the movie is the beginning of the relationship. You don't really get to see how it goes, how he gets too clingy, one of them meets someone else, how it just fades. But that is not this story.
在电影里，这通常是最后一幕。电影的结尾是恋情的开始。你没法看到之后会怎样，他如何变得粘人，其中一个人遇到别人，爱情如何消散。但这可不是那个故事。
We got married, and now we have two kids. And I still can't believe it's all played out the way it did.
我们结婚了，现在有了两个孩子。我依然不敢相信一切竟然就这样发生了。
I know things don't always work out in the end, but sometimes you just want to hear the ones that do.
我知道事情并不总是在最后圆满，但有时你就是想听那些圆满的。
David Kestenbaum is one of the producers of our show.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Four, You Had Me at Hello.
第四幕，你一开口就征服了我。
So after Harry does his run across New York City on New Year's Eve and reaches Sally, he explains to her that he ran because, once you realize you want to spend the rest of your life with somebody, you want the rest of your life to start as soon as possible. And he tells her all the things about her that he notices and loves about her.
所以在哈利跨越纽约城在新年前夜完成奔跑并找到莎莉后，他向她解释他之所以奔跑是因为，一旦你意识到你想和某人共度余生，你就希望余生越早开始越好。他告诉她所有他注意到并喜欢的关于她的特质。
That's the final thing you need for a rom-com. You need for somebody to declare that they see you in ways that you're usually not seen-- maybe you don't even know yourself. And it does happen in real life sometimes after some obstacles. Diane Wu has a story like that.
这是浪漫喜剧所需的最后一样东西。你需要某人宣称他看到了你通常不被看到的一面——也许连你自己都不知道。这种情况在现实中偶尔也会在克服一些障碍后发生。戴安·吴有这样一个故事。
She fell for him in an acting class. Jillian was a serious young actor bent over her desk taking notes when Geoffrey got up in front of class to read from A Midsummer Night's Dream.
她在表演课上爱上了他。吉莉安是一个认真的年轻演员，弯腰在桌前做笔记，这时杰弗里走到班级前面朗读《仲夏夜之梦》。
I just remember hearing his voice first and then actually looking up from my notebook and just watching him do the scene. And he was so, so good. And he had this really awesome voice. It's super low and really resonant, and he was really hot, too.
我只记得先听到了他的声音，然后才从笔记本里抬起头，看着他演那场戏。他真的太棒了。而且他的声音非常迷人。非常低沉，很有共鸣，而且他本人也很帅。
By the time he sat back down, she was done.
当他坐回去时，她已经被征服了。
I was immediately more attracted to him than I'd ever felt attracted to anybody before. And I didn't know how to talk to him. I just knew that I wanted to talk to him, but I just didn't know how. It was like a mix between wanting to be right next to somebody and then run away and hide.
我立刻感到对他产生了一种前所未有的吸引力。我不知道该怎么跟他搭讪。我只知道我想跟他说话，但我不知道怎么开口。那就像是想待在某人身边，却又想跑走躲起来的混合心态。
Jillian was young, 20. She'd had boyfriends, but nothing too serious. And they'd always liked her more than she liked them, until Geoffrey. They were working together at a Shakespeare theater in New York. At the end, they put on a production of The Winter's Tale.
吉莉安很年轻，20岁。她交过男友，但都不太认真。他们总是比她喜欢他们更喜欢她，直到杰弗里的出现。他们在纽约的一家莎士比亚剧院工作。最后，他们排演了《冬天的故事》。
Onstage, she'd sometimes gets so distracted that he was there that she'd forget her lines. Sometimes offstage, she thought maybe Geoffrey was flirting with her, but she couldn't tell for sure. And anyway, she had a rule, never sleep with a cast mate. So for four months, she kept her feelings to herself.
在台上，她有时会因为他在场而分心，甚至忘记台词。有时在台下，她觉得杰弗里可能在撩她，但她不敢确定。总之，她有一条原则：绝对不跟搭档上床。所以整整四个月，她把感觉藏在心里。
Cut to the night of the final cast party. Everyone's at the bar that they always go to, and it's the first night they're no longer coworkers. So on her way over, Jillian makes it her mission to try and kiss him that night. She talks to him a lot at the party, but keeps chickening out. Finally, she gives up and decides to go home.
场景切到演职员杀青派对的晚上。每个人都在他们常去的那家酒吧，这是他们不再是同事的第一晚。所以去酒吧的路上，吉莉安把那天晚上亲吻他当作使命。她在派对上跟他聊了很多，但总是临阵退缩。最后，她放弃了，决定回家。
And so I was standing there, and I was getting ready to hail a cab, finishing up the end of the cigarette, and I felt him come up next to me. And yeah, he just-- it was kind of like-- I remember him just like brushing back hair kind of off of my cheek. And it's that moment, you know, where you know that you're actually going to kiss. You just feel it in your two bodies. And he just so very lightly pressed his lips up against mine. And then it was like, well, now like an actual deeper kiss. And I know from the outside, we made it look good, because it very much felt like one of those-- like a good stage kiss.
所以我就站在那儿，准备拦辆出租车，抽完最后一口烟，我感觉到他走到了我身边。然后，是的，他只是……我记得他把我的头发从脸颊上拨开。那一刻，你知道，你知道你们真的要接吻了。你只是在两人的身体里感受到了。他轻轻地把嘴唇压在我的唇上。然后就像，嗯，现在变成了一个真正的深吻。我知道从外面看，我们看起来不错，因为它确实很像电影里的那种——那种高质量的舞台之吻。
After their perfect first kiss, everything falls into place on cue. He invites her back to his apartment. She flicks her cigarette to the curb. He opens the door to the cab. She glides into the backseat. More kissing ensues.
在他们完美的初吻后，一切按计划进行。他邀请她回公寓。她把烟头弹向路边。他打开出租车的车门。她滑进后座。更多的亲吻随之而来。
And I think that's probably the first time I've ever made out with anybody in the back of a cab. [LAUGHS] I think I was probably like, oh, this cab driver's here.
我觉得这可能是我第一次在出租车后座跟人激吻。（笑）我想当时我可能在想，噢，出租车司机在这儿。
They make out all the way across Manhattan, over a bridge, and up five flights of stairs. Somehow, Geoffrey manages to unlock the door without removing his lips from Jillian's. This impresses her very much. Everything is going so perfectly.
他们穿过曼哈顿，跨过一座桥，爬上五层楼，整个过程一直在激吻。杰弗里不知怎的竟然在不离开吉莉安嘴唇的情况下打开了门。这让她印象非常深刻。一切都进行得如此完美。
So then I use his bathroom because I've been drinking a lot of beer all night. And I'm so nervous. I notice that my hands are shaking in the mirror. I'm so nervous. And I just look myself in the eye, and I actually gave myself a pep talk, like pointer fingers and dancing in the mirror and being like, this is everything you've waited for. It's actually happening. It's like excitement, nervous, I believe in you. Yeah.
于是我去用了他的洗手间，因为我整晚都在喝啤酒。我非常紧张。我注意到我的手在镜子前发抖。我太紧张了。我看着自己的眼睛，甚至给了自己一段心理建设，比如竖起食指，在镜子前跳舞，并对自己说：这就是你等待的一切。它真的发生了。这就像兴奋、紧张，我相信你。耶。
Then Jillian encounters the first obstacle in what will turn out to be a very strange night for her.
然后吉莉安遇到了一个在这一晚将会变得非常奇怪的第一个障碍。
And my whole heart just sinks. And I'm not actually going to be able to have sex with him. I just got my period. I realize that making out with him in the back of the cab and just my cigarettes and my leather jacket, you know, it makes me seem like I was this really cool city girl, but the reality of who I am is this very nervous person who grew up very conservative, like very, very conservative.
我整颗心都沉了下去。我实际上没法和他发生关系。我刚好生理期。我意识到和他坐在出租车后座激吻，加上我的烟和皮衣，你知道，这让我看起来像是个很酷的城市女孩，但真实的我是个非常紧张的人，在非常保守的环境下长大，真的很保守。
Jillian grew up on a farm in rural Canada. This one time when she was young and got her period while wearing white pants, her whole family participated in a weird game of denial. Everyone just pretended like she sat in some jam. She didn't even like to say the word period.
吉莉安在加拿大乡村的一个农场长大。有一次她年轻时穿白裤子碰上生理期，她全家竟然参与了一场奇怪的否认游戏。大家只是假装她坐到了果酱上。她甚至不喜欢说“生理期”这个词。
It was something that was kind of like very hush-hush and not something I was used to discussing openly.
这是那种非常避讳的事情，不是我习惯公开讨论的东西。
Jillian thinks, there's no way we can sleep together tonight. So she's disappointed, and she's stressing over how she's even going to tell him. But she can't hide in the bathroom much longer. He's waiting on the other side of the door.
吉莉安想，今晚没法上床了。她很失望，压力很大，在想该怎么告诉他。但她没法在洗手间躲太久。他在门外等着。
So I left the bathroom, and it was like I stepped out into another world, this romantic world where he'd actually taken a scarf and put it over a lamp, so the lighting was this orange mood lighting. And he didn't have a shirt on. And my mind remembers him glistening. He probably wasn't actually glistening, but that's how my mind remembers him.
我离开了洗手间，感觉就像步入了另一个世界，这个浪漫的世界，他甚至用一条围巾罩住了灯，所以灯光变成了橙色的氛围感照明。他没穿衬衫。我的记忆里他全身在发光。他可能实际上并没有在发光，但我的记忆里他就是那样。
We checked. Her mind remembers right. Geoffrey told me, and he said, yes, this was very embarrassing looking back, but while she was in the bathroom, he slathered on baby oil to make his muscles pop. Anyway, they start to kiss.
我们确认了一下。她的记忆是对的。杰弗里告诉我说，是的，回想起来这很尴尬，但在她上厕所的时候，他抹上了婴儿油来让肌肉显眼。总之，他们开始接吻。
And I remember at first being really into it, and then remembering my situation. So my mouth does that thing where it curls up a little bit. And we kind of laugh a bit and he goes in to kiss me again, and I do that thing where I pull away again. And he was so sweet. He was like, wait, what's going on? You know, he noticed it. He read it right away, and was like, we don't have to do this. I want to be clear, nothing is expected of you in this situation. We don't have to have sex.
我记得起初非常投入，然后想起了我的处境。所以我的嘴做出了那种有点蜷缩的样子。我们笑了笑，他凑过来又想亲我，我又把头转开了。他非常贴心。他说，等等，发生什么事了？你知道，他注意到了。他一眼就看穿了，说，我们不必做这个。我想说明白，在这种情况下不强求任何事。我们不必上床。
And I was like, I want to. I really-- like I honestly-- I want to. It's just-- and I kept trying to think of, how am I going to phrase this? I think of this thing that my roommate used to say. She calls it her Aunt Flo. So I look at him, and I tell him that my Aunt Flo has just landed and she's very much in town. And he gets a little bit confused.
我说，我想。我真的很想……我真心想。只是……我一直在想，该怎么表达？我想起室友常说的一句话。她叫它“佛罗小姐”。所以我看着他，告诉他，我的“佛罗小姐”刚刚降落，她非常想进城。他有点困惑。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
He asked me if my Aunt has just arrived at the airport and if I have to go see her or something. So eventually, I just fess up. And I tell him, no, I have my period. And I'm pretty sure I whispered it. I'm pretty sure I was like, I have my (QUIETLY) period. And he smiled this half-smile and was like, so? I was like, so? What do you mean, so? And he just-- he didn't care.
他问我我的阿姨是不是刚到机场，我是否得去见她什么的。所以最后，我只能坦白。我告诉他，不，我生理期了。我肯定我是小声说的。我肯定是那种（轻声）生理期。他露出了半个微笑说，所以呢？我说，所以呢？你什么意思？他根本不在乎。
He didn't care. He was older than her, grew up with a bunch of sisters. Jillian is briefly astonished, considers this totally new possibility, not caring, decides she's into it, and they start kissing again. And because this is a family show, I will just say that everything that happened next went really well. In fact, it was the first time this particular activity went quite so well for Jillian.
他不在乎。他比她大，和一群姐妹一起长大。吉莉安短暂地惊讶了一下，考虑了这个全新的可能性，不在乎，决定她很享受，于是他们又开始接吻。因为这是一档合家欢节目，我只能说接下来发生的一切进行得非常顺利。事实上，这是这项特定活动对吉莉安来说第一次进行得如此顺利。
I felt like I finally understood what it was about. I remember lying there and listening to his heartbeat. Yeah, and just listening to his heartbeat was such a comforting sound that I can still hear it so distinctly. And after a while, he gets up to go to the bathroom, and he kind of flicks on that little light.
我觉得我终于明白了这到底是怎么回事。我记得躺在那儿听他的心跳。是的，仅仅听他的心跳声就是一种如此安慰的声音，我至今依然能清晰地听到。过了一会儿，他起来去洗手间，他顺手打开了那盏小灯。
She's talking about the lamp by the bed.
她说的是床头灯。
And I turn off that light. And he flicks it on again, and then I turn it back off. And we have this little shared moment laughter. And he leaves, and I turn the light on again, and it looks like a crime scene. There is blood everywhere. This is the first time I had seen so much of my own menstrual fluid. I was afraid of it. I couldn't even fathom what he was going to think about it.
我关掉了灯。他又打开，我又关掉。我们分享了一个小小的时刻，笑了笑。他离开后，我又打开了灯，那看起来像犯罪现场。到处都是血。这是我第一次看到这么多自己的经血。我很害怕。我甚至无法想象他会怎么想。
Just when Jillian thinks it can't get worse, she looks up from the bed.
就在吉莉安觉得情况不能更糟时，她看向床那边。
And then I don't know how this happened, but my very own like red, bloody hand print is on his white wall.
然后我不知道怎么发生的，我自己的那个红色、血淋淋的手印就在他的白墙上。
[GASPS] Oh, my god.
（惊呼）天哪。
I just panicked.
我当时就崩溃了。
Jillian tears the sheets off the bed and throws them aside. Next, the hand print.
吉莉安把床单扯下来扔到一边。接下来是那个手印。
He didn't have any water or anything in his room, so I used my own saliva to wipe the bloody hand print off of the wall, like, out, out, damn spot.
他的房间里没有水或其他东西，所以我用自己的唾液去擦墙上血淋淋的手印，就像《麦克白》里的那句：去吧，该死的点。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Next, she bundles up the sheets, but she has no idea what to do with them. She starts to put them in the hamper, but then realizes that he would still have to take them and wash them himself, which she cannot bear to imagine. She peeks under his bed to see if she can stash them there, but then she thinks, no, no, that's crazy. He'll still find them. Geoffrey will be out of the bathroom any minute. She's running out of options.
接下来，她把床单团在一起，但她不知道该拿它们怎么办。她开始把它塞进脏衣篮，但意识到如果这样，他还是得自己拿去洗，她简直不敢想象那场面。她看看床底下能不能藏，但想了想，不，不，太疯狂了。他还是会发现的。杰弗里随时会从洗手间出来。她快没招了。
So I stuff them into my own backpack.
于是我把它们塞进了我自己的背包。
Wait, were you going to take them?
等等，你是要带走它们？
Oh, yeah. Well, I have to get out of there.
噢，是的。嗯，我得离开那儿。
You're not going to get away with that, though. He's going to notice his sheets are gone.
你可瞒不过去，他会发现床单不见了。
I know, but I wasn't thinking about that at the time. All I could think of is that I didn't want him to have to wash these sheets. And I didn't want him to have to clean up my mess, I guess.
我知道，但我当时根本没想那么多。我满脑子想的只是不想让他不得不洗这些床单。我也不想让他清理我的烂摊子，我想是这样。
To cover her tracks, Jillian throws the comforter over the bed so you can't see the sheets are missing, straightens the pillows, and gets ready to bolt. When Geoffrey comes back from the shower, she makes up a lame excuse about why she can't stay the night, something about having to go to work early the next morning. She could tell how flimsy it sounded as she was saying it.
为了掩盖行踪，吉莉安把被子盖在床上，这样就看不出床单不见了，理好枕头，准备冲出去。当杰弗里洗完澡出来时，她编了一个蹩脚的理由，比如明天一大早要工作。她说的时候就感觉到这理由有多脆弱。
And I just, oh, it breaks my heart, but I remember him looking so hurt and so confused. I wish that I didn't leave. Like, I wish that I had stayed, but--
我心都要碎了，我记得他看起来非常受伤和困惑。我希望我没离开。比如，我希望我留下来，但——
She didn't. Geoffrey offered to help Jillian hail a cab, but she was like, no, it's fine. I'll just take the subway. She walked to the station, totally miserable.
她没留下。杰弗里提出帮吉莉安拦出租车，但她说，不用，没关系。我会坐地铁。她走向车站，心情糟糕透顶。
Then it really hits me that I have stolen this man's sheets. How do you come back from that? How do you-- how are you not the weird girl who took his bedsheets?
然后我真的意识到我偷了这个男人的床单。这该怎么补救？你怎么能不成为那个偷了他床单的怪女孩？
Yeah.
是啊。
So then I'm so inside myself and I hear this voice being like, ma'am, excuse me, ma'am. And I look up. And in New York, they have this station outside of subway entrances with this folding table and the NYPD stands behind. And it's a random bag search.
所以我正沉浸在自我怀疑里，听到一个声音说，女士，不好意思，女士。我抬头看。在纽约，他们会在地铁入口外设有个折叠桌，纽约警察站在后面。这是随机检查包。
No!
不！
And here, Jillian does what any sensible leading lady would do when confronted by law enforcement.
在这里，吉莉安做了任何一位精明的女主角在面对执法人员时都会做的事。
I pretend I don't hear them. And I try to exit the subway station in like a brisk, like, run-walk. And nothing looks more suspicious than trying to avoid a random bag search.
我假装没听见他们。我试图以一种轻快、竞走的方式离开地铁站。没有任何东西比试图逃避随机包检查看起来更可疑了。
I'm sure. I'm sure.
我肯定。我肯定。
Yeah. Oh.
是啊。噢。
The officer catches up to Jillian, unzips her backpack, and pulls out the sheets, which are covered in blood.
警察追上吉莉安，拉开她的背包拉链，掏出了沾满鲜血的床单。
I remember him-- and the subway has such distinct lighting, like I just remember him holding up these sheets, my menstrual sheets of shame, like menstrual sheets of doom. I realize that they didn't look like menstrual sheets of doom, they looked like murder sheets of doom.
我记得他——地铁里的灯光很独特，我记得他举着这些床单，我羞耻的经血床单，就像末日的经血床单。我意识到它们看起来不像末日的经血床单，它们看起来像末日的谋杀床单。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
He asked me to explain it, and I just start crying. And I can barely get the words out. I'm just trying to explain to him, it's my period on those sheets. And I stole the sheets from the guy that I was with. And I know that that's wrong. Like I know that the actual theft of the sheets is wrong. And I promised the officer that I would return them, but I just needed to wash them first.
他让我解释，我当时就开始哭。话都说不出来。我只是试图向他解释，那是床单上的生理期经血。而我偷了那床单，从跟我在一起的那个男人那儿。我知道那是错的。我知道实际的偷窃行为是错的。我向警察保证我会归还它们，但我只是需要先洗洗。
The police officer looks Jillian up and down, asks for her ID, and points her to go stand in a little box taped on the floor by the wall. She watches him walk over to his partner and have a very serious-looking conversation. The sheets stay crumpled up on the plastic folding table.
警察打量了吉莉安一番，要了她的证件，并让她去站在折叠桌旁墙上贴好的小盒子里。她看着他走过去和他同伴进行了一场看起来很严肃的谈话。床单团成一团放在塑料折叠桌上。
Then he comes back, and gives me an ultimatum. So we can go down to the precinct and they can file a report and they've got to keep the sheets just in case it's evidence, you know, and they're going to ask me a bunch of questions and follow up, or I can take him back to the apartment, the apartment that I just came from, and have my partner corroborate my story.
然后他回来，给了我最后通牒。我们可以去警察局，他们可以备案，他们得扣押床单以防作为证据，你知道，他们会问我一堆问题并追踪调查，或者我可以带他回刚才那个公寓，带我去的那间，让我男友为我的话做旁证。
Oh, my god.
天哪。
And I had to think about it. Like, I honestly-- like, I honestly gave it a really solid, good think. There was a huge part of me that would rather go to the police station than have to go back and show Jeffery these-- not only show him these sheets, but also bring the police there. But, you know, my common sense caught up with me of, this looks like I've done something very wrong.
我得考虑一下。我真心……我真心给了它一个非常扎实、认真的考虑。我内心有很大一部分宁可去警察局，也不想回去告诉杰弗里这些——不仅仅是向他展示这些床单，还得带警察过去。但是，你知道，我的常识占了上风，这看起来像我做了什么非常严重的事。
They make the long walk to Geoffrey's apartment, silently. They get to the doorstep and buzz, wait for Geoffrey to walk down five flights of stairs. When he gets there, the police officer does all the talking.
他们沉默地走了很长的路回到杰弗里的公寓。走到门口按响门铃，等着杰弗里走下五层楼。当他到达时，警察说了所有的话。
Good evening, do you know this woman? Geoffrey says he does, that they'd just been hanging out. Then the cop reaches into Jillian's backpack and pulls out the sheets. Do you know what these are? Geoffrey says, those are my sheets. The police officer asks, can you identify the substance on these sheets?
晚上好，你认识这个女人吗？杰弗里说认识，他们刚才一起玩的。然后警察伸手进吉莉安的背包掏出床单。你知道这是什么吗？杰弗里说，那是我的床单。警察问，你能辨认出床单上的物质吗？
And I just remember being fascinated, because without hesitating and almost in this stronger voice, he just says, menstrual fluid, which is like-- you know, I would call my period anything other than what it actually was. So for him to look a police officer right in the eyes and just say very confidently, menstrual fluid, it was just-- it sounded so scientific and very grown up.
我记得我很着迷，因为他没有犹豫，而且声音几乎变得更有力，他只是说：经血。那感觉就像——你知道，我过去会把我的生理期称为除了真实情况之外的任何东西。所以他看着警察的眼睛，非常自信地说是“经血”，那听起来如此科学，非常成熟。
The cops, having fulfilled their narrative purpose and successfully reunited our couple, leave.
警察履行了他们的叙事目的并成功让我们的情侣团聚后，离开了。
And then I'm alone with Geoffrey. And I'm trying to apologize to him, namely for stealing his sheets, but also just for everything, for bringing the police back to his house.
然后我就和杰弗里独处了。我试图向他道歉，主要是因为偷了他的床单，也为了这一切，因为把警察带回他家。
Jillian remembers sobbing through all of this. She's mortified. All of a sudden, Geoffrey stops her and says this thing that still hits Jillian in a soft spot.
吉莉安记得哭着说完了这一切。她丢脸死了。突然，杰弗里打断她，说了这句话，这句话至今仍击中吉莉安柔软的地方。
He told me-- I just remember him looking at me and he's like, you're so strange. [LAUGHS] He said, wonderfully strange. Everything that you could possibly think of going wrong went wrong, and it all still turned out OK. He still liked me, no matter what.
他告诉我——我记得看着他，他说：你真奇怪。（笑）他说，美妙地奇怪。所有可能出错的事情都出错了，但最后一切都还好。无论如何，他依然喜欢我。
This is like my favorite moment in any rom-com. It's the scene in 10 Things I Hate About You when Julia Stiles reads her poem to Heath Ledger in front of the entire class. It's Jack Nicholson in As Good As It Gets telling Helen Hunt how he just can't believe she runs into strangers all day long, and they don't know that they just met the greatest woman alive. And of course, it's Mark Darcy at the bottom of the stairs telling Bridget Jones, I like you very much, just as you are.
这是我最喜欢的浪漫喜剧瞬间。那是《我恨你的十件事》中朱莉娅·斯泰尔斯在全班面前给希斯·莱杰读诗的一幕。那是《尽善尽美》中杰克·尼科尔森告诉海伦·亨特他是多么无法相信她整天遇到陌生人，而他们不知道自己遇到了世上最伟大的女性。当然，还有《BJ单身日记》结尾马克·达西站在楼梯下对她说：我很喜欢你，就喜欢现在的你。
To me, the whole point of rom-coms is to set up that line. It's what we all want to hear and say to the people we love most. But real life doesn't guarantee a plot line that pushes us to say it.
对我来说，浪漫喜剧的全部意义就是铺垫那句台词。那是我们都想听到并对我们最爱的人说的话。但现实生活并不能保证一个推动我们去说出它的情节。
Diane Wu, she's one of the producers of our show. Jillian and Geoffrey dated for a few months, and then they broke it off when real life, new jobs, her expired visa from Canada, got in the way. She says she's glad it ended before anything bad happened. Keeps the memory sweet, just like a movie. Today, Jillian Welsh is a comedian in Toronto. A version of this story first aired on the RISK! Podcast.
戴安·吴，她是我们的制作人之一。吉莉安和杰弗里约会了几个月，然后在现实生活——新工作、她来自加拿大的过期签证——横插一脚时分手了。她说她很高兴一切在坏事发生前结束了。保留了甜蜜的回忆，就像一部电影。如今，吉莉安·威尔什是多伦多的一名喜剧演员。这个故事的版本最初在 RISK! 播客上播出。
Our program is produced today by Neil Drumming and Diane Wu. The people who put our show together includes Elna Baker, Elise Bergerson, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Stephanie Foo, Damien Grave, Kimberly Henderson, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Alvin Melathe, BA Parker, Ben Phelan, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierny, and Julie Whitaker. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton.
我们的节目由尼尔·德拉明和戴安·吴制作。节目组成员包括埃尔娜·贝克、埃莉斯·伯格森、本·卡尔霍恩、达纳·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德、斯蒂芬妮·福、达米恩·格雷夫、金伯利·亨德森、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆、赛斯·林德、阿尔文·梅拉特、BA·帕克、本·菲兰、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和朱莉·惠特克。高级制作人是布莱恩·里德。主编是苏珊·伯顿。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（鸣谢）
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，《美国生活》由 PRX 公共广播交换平台发送至各公共广播电台。
Quick program note, our colleagues at our home station, WBEZ Chicago have a new podcast called Making Obama about Barack Obama's early years in Chicago, which features him, his friends, mentors, and rivals talking about his years in Chicago and his rise. It's six episodes, stuff I have never heard or read before about him. Making Obama, get it wherever you get your podcasts.
节目快讯，我们在母台芝加哥WBEZ的同事有一个名为《Making Obama》的新播客，讲述巴拉克·奥巴马在芝加哥的早年生活，由他本人、朋友、导师和竞争对手讲述他在芝加哥岁月及崛起的历程。共有六集，里面有很多我从未听说或读过的关于他的事。《Making Obama》，在你获取播客的地方即可收听。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he and I were reminiscing about that taxi ride we had years ago in England with Margaret Thatcher.
一如既往地感谢本节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，当年在英国，我和他曾回忆起那次和玛格丽特·撒切尔一起坐的出租车。
And I think that's probably the first time I'd ever made out with anybody in the back of a cab.
而且那可能是我第一次在出租车后座跟人激吻。
I'm Ira Glass. Happy Valentine's Day. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。情人节快乐。下周同一时间带来更多《美国生活》的故事。